it's an industry which interrupts the
stunning Vista of Kenya's Rift Valley
for mile after mile giant tents spring
up from the soil the infrastructure of
this nation's second largest export
business and one critical to the local
economy
inside the greenhouses you get a sense
of the sheer scale of the flower
operation this company alone produces a
million stems a day 365 million a year
but not a single one is destined for the
dining rooms and sideboards of African
homes this is the packing home for
therian so we have 50 to 900 people
working here every day
and those workers are focused on
supplying huge quantities of fresh
flowers to a European market including
the UK which has long looked to Kenya
especially for roses if you pick up a
bouquet in a supermarket in London
Birmingham or Manchester there's a good
chance it'll have come from here these
bouquets will be going to the United
Kingdom yeah so these will be on the
supermarket shelf in possibly two to
three days and we'll ship them to
Nairobi and then I'll go through and
those flights take off every single day
of the week with us Arian company
flowers on board 80% of the produce
leaves Kenya by air this is a vast
operation employing 4,500 people on-site
growing packing and shipping flowers to
meet global demands but what if that
demand were to fall because of a
European push to reduce air freight
imports what would happen to this
workforce
twenty-four-year-old in vallata cheap
cause guy says without this work people
will face poverty her income has to take
care of a family of five there's little
of the work here in the Naivasha region
north of Nairobi
if this Petroleum's be here we'll lose a
lot of job because most of the people I
hear they're what ugly working they are
here to earn their living this is where
they defend where their school fees
their basic needs and everything that
they need in their homes this is where
they get their money to support
themselves the packets here
earn twenty five dollars a week but in
vallata works extra hours at busy times
like Valentine's and Mother's Day the
company provides a crash free schools
and housing in vallata takes us to the
home she shares with her family it's
just a single room where they must all
eat sleep and live but she says it's
better than no home at all if they
couldn't be there wouldn't lose a lot
because most of our kids are there if
you see we depend on that factory
actually yes everything is done about
that factory yeah parts of Kenya's
flower industry which employs a hundred
thousand people directly and over two
million in the chain have long faced
criticism for poor wages working and
living conditions now its environmental
record is in question with its over
reliance on air transport and a push by
many in the West to buy locally but as a
serían where they've reduced their
carbon footprint by recycling water
cutting packaging and using electric
vehicles bosses say transportation is
only part of the green picture you can
see some of our projects here funded by
big supermarkets in the UK so we we are
fond of this market and we wouldn't want
to miss it and would I wish they could
appreciate their contribution to this
market and how much that has has made a
difference so the carbon footprint
conversation only just MLS there's much
more and she insists it's still more
environmentally friendly to mass-produce
flowers in a warm climate than the UK
but this industry which has been built
on European demand now fears decline
because of a European push to cut carbon
emissions he may be a laudable aim but
it will have consequences
Michele Clifford Sky News Naivasha
Kenya